welcome to ear biscuits the podcast with
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm rhett and i'm link this
week at the round table of dim lighting
i finally get to hear about your spring
break
epic road trip with your man with your
oldest son
you did the
the you did the long way around in just
in america like a few months back you
went from north carolina back here to
california on a on a unlock road trip
and now i've done the long way down from
maine to miami yeah so that's what we're
doing greg you weren't on uh
motorbikes no you and mcgregor and apple
was not interested in documenting it
no and you're going to document it now
auditorially for me
there's been a number of times
we've gotten together with friends and
they've asked you about your trip and i
really appreciate the fact that you
completely shut them down yeah because i
was getting ready to tell
i'm excited about it i'm excited to tell
you about it so you preserve this
experience for me it's going to take a
while
there's a lot of details all right
let's get into it but i do also want to
remind you that our television show yes
we have one of those
inside eats with rhett and link yes
remember it premieres on
uh sunday april 24th this coming sunday
as as as you're listening to this if
it's fresh
10 30 p.m on food network it's also on
discovery plus and the version on
discovery plus has extra scenes in it
because you don't have to abide by any
rules
eat it up on streaming inside east we
run link oh it's premiering i'm excited
yeah this coming sunday all right
tell me about your thing man this isn't
this is ambitious i like it conceptually
you know well you know the funny thing
is is that i mean to miami i didn't have
any road trips planned at the at the end
of 2021
uh
the the first road trip that i talked
about last time was a complete just
circumstantial thing
of kind of being forced into it in in a
sense and we had such a great time that
we eventually initially we wanted to go
to like
you know we lock and i want wanted to do
spring break trip the spring break trip
like in japan
but then that didn't happen and then
it's everything got slowly like uh
paired back to just remaining in the
united states and it was like let's go
to maine
and then let's go to maine turned into
well there's a college in new york city
that i'm interested in turned so that
turned into maine to new york turned
into well we got that new cabin in in
north carolina if you're a little
rattling barbara is walking around her
cat her i don't know if the mic is
picking it up but just don't be alarmed
it's not like it's not your change my
dentures are not about to fall out
uh they're um
it's barbara and also
uh
so we got the place in north carolina so
then it turned into maine to north
carolina and then lot was like well what
about that school in miami that i'm
interested in that i'd like to look at
so that turned out further than north
korea that turned into maine to miami
and i also like the alliteration of the
maine to miami mclaughlin marathon oh uh
and so we just went with it so you ran
yeah it was all on the foot
actually on skateboard how many days
total was this trip it was just to kind
of set the price seven days so seven
days
less mileage
than going from uh
north carolina to california and more
days so we did north carolina to
california in five days we did maine in
miami in seven days barbara you're gonna
have to settle down just take her um
take her caller okay i'm gonna take her
other collar off come here come here
come here come here
she's going to make you come to her
i've been to maine once
we shot a music video i want to be your
main man
in 2008.
that was fun fake beards just a few
hours there ate my first lobster roll
i've been to miami
twice i think
um
we did some night swimming when we shot
the
big box store part of the
epic rap battle
nerd vs geek
that was shot in a miami and there's a
little throwback to that trip build.com
box store
so
um
flew into portland maine that was
originally we were going to fly into
like the northern part of maine because
it was going to be maine but then when
you're trying when when you're trying to
just
get across the the country you fly to
the southern part of maine which is also
like the airport that you can fly to
from
uh
you know there's no direct flights from
los angeles to portland there's a
connection in charlotte
but we because of the time change we got
in and basically the only thing we had
time to do was was go to the hotel to
kind of just like let's let's settle
down
and uh and go to sleep and get ready for
the next day
but let me tell you right off the bat i
had something that i was like well dang
this is gonna be quite a trip
because we get to our hotel
and again just this is lock
and me
lock is 18.
he doesn't look 18. he he has somewhat
of a beard
um
you know he he is mistaken often he
could be in his 20s yeah mid-20s uh
yeah so he seems like he's in his 20s
i'm 44 and i like to think that most
people don't realize that i'm that old
so when you see us together you don't
immediately apparently think father and
son okay maybe you do i don't know and
as i tell you this story you'll have to
interpret what
what this person interpreted us to be
we get on the elevator i think i would
interpret you as
young pop star and
a manager oh and i'm the pop star
i know
uh and so
we
get on the elevator to go to our room
and a approximately 25 year old woman
gets onto the elevator
and
it's just the three of us on the
elevator and
no lie so she looks at us and she looks
i'll i'll just be honest she looks
mostly at lock okay she looks mostly at
lock i'm just gonna be honest but she
looks at both of us she seems to be
interpreting us as a set
and she says before the elevator door
closes like as the elevator door closes
she says
how long are you guys here
and
i said uh
one night
not uh not really knowing where this was
going i'm gonna stand here one night and
then she said
we should hang out
we should hang out
and it was i was like whoa the women in
maine they've been they've been cooped
up yeah
the boys from california show up and how
long are you going to be here
they come on strong
what'd y'all do i guess it's in the
lobster i mean lobster
shellfish is an aphrodisiac
so apparently
um
it's it is something in the diet but
i spoke up
and said
uh well actually we were gonna go it was
the the the
it wasn't the final four yet it was the
week it was the elite eight and there
was a game on and we wanted to watch it
because we both care about that
and then
i was like we got to watch basketball
i'm just like what's the uh what's the
unsexiest thing that i can say right now
we gotta watch basketball
you know
i wasn't gonna like
embarrass you i don't know you know that
maybe i need to pop my back zit
like i'm his dad i could have just said
that uh but i decided not to because
maybe she would be like oh i knew that
you know i don't know this is a maine
woman no i think she's an oyster she
probably would have just said i was
talking to him uh well she didn't say
that i know
uh so i'm gonna bring you down or not so
no as i started to say it from the
beginning she was definitely directing
most of this at lock you know
uh
so
i was like this is gonna be an
interesting trip if this is any
indication of what we have in store for
us uh thankfully we were not hit on by
any more women so i can go ahead and
give you that alert but that next
morning we wake up and the plan is to
spend some time in portland and
specifically kind of walk around the old
port area which is like cobblestone
streets like the main
manius part of portland maine
and i had actually gotten to know
somebody
just like two weeks ago out here who has
a place in maine and is from maine and
had all these recommendations and i was
like well the main thing i'm trying to
do in maine is get the best lobster roll
you know i've had a lobster roll or two
in maine before the first time we went
but like what in your opinion
as a local
is the best lobster roll
and he was like
even tied
eventide in portland
so i was like okay well you have your
mission and he was like he also gave a
couple of other recommendations they're
like there's a bakery that everybody
wants to go to for a cup of coffee and
some bread or whatever you know a little
pastry
whatever but just tell me about event
but the plan was
you know i kind of wanted to get on the
road because i had a relatively
tight agenda
meaning that there was a destination
every single night because there was a
hotel reservation so unlike the previous
trip which was thrown together a little
bit more last minute
and we used like hotels tonight to
figure out where we were going to stay
in that first trip this one was like i
actually want to curate my hotel
experience
and i don't know exactly what we're
going to do during the day every day but
we just got to get to these destinations
yeah we had some place to get and
originally my plan was to just spend a
little time in portland and then get on
the road
to uh to boston then eventually rhode
island to spend the night
but when he was like you got to eat it
even tight i was like well it opens at
11. so we're gonna have to like walk
around and do and kill some time in
portland and get a brunch lobster roll
so
first of all maine is everything that
you want it to be you know it's quaint
it's beautiful it's quaint it's got a
there's a coolness in the air it was
actually too cold uh for me
and i didn't bring it have enough jacket
but i you know i got through it i
survived
but we get to eventide and uh i think
it's called event oyster company so we
did get some oysters
and like the woman was like this place
was like not like a
this wasn't
like a hole in the wall this was like a
hipster nice place
you know what i mean like oh this this
community um has got some like really
nice it's like someplace you'd see in la
in terms of like this is they know
exactly what they're doing with the
design of the place it's not like an old
school place that's been maybe it's been
around for a long time but it has the
feel of like a new trendy place
but just
uh it has this reputation and i like
yelp and everything else confirmed that
this is the place to get your lobster
roll
so the oysters are great talking about
where they're at in the different bays
of maine or whatever
and then they bring out the lobster roll
and by the way there was a mythical
beast uh fan in the back in the kitchen
uh which made me feel good like i wasn't
gonna i wasn't gonna
uh we ended up getting like a free
cookie
okay which is very like what you can get
man but this lobster roll
was about this big and that is short
four inches
okay don't get any wrong ideas this is
only four inches it's dinky and
yeah and
21. whoa is it piled high or something
it is piled high
i have a picture of it that
they're probably seeing right now if
you're watching on video
i'm not going to show you pictures
because i haven't organized it
this lobster roll
was
exquisite now you know i like lobster
rolls is it crunchy or soft uh the bun
was
soft in this like
wonderful way i can't i don't even know
what kind of bread it was okay and it
was the brown butter like warm kind
right
so you know i love lobster rolls i had a
lobster roll truck at my 40th birthday
yeah
i like the warm ones and better than the
cake and they would do cold or or or hot
and i love the the hot brown butter
style
and
the lobster was just perfect
and i was like man this is a lot of
money for a little lobster roll i
immediately want another one but we had
multiple stops planned in the day like
eating was really the main thing we were
trying to do
and in the process of eating it
i dropped a freaking piece of lobster on
the ground oh no
and my by my math it was approximately
three dollars and 75 cents worth out
lobster
was it dirt or linoleum did you pick it
up
well we were sitting at a like you know
one of those like high bars facing out
the window and so in order to get the
lobster off of the ground i would have
to
get off of the stool and bend down cause
a scene or use both of your feet
oh let me tell you i considered it i
considered it that's a shame considered
it multiple times
but i let it sit there
but then i did proceed to tell uh the
waiter i was like by the way there's
some lobster on the the ground um
before i had time to like get up and get
it i was just like dogs want you to
understand like
i really value the lobster i was kind of
hoping he would be like well we'll bring
you another piece
really but you're trying to angle for
another piece of lobster uh so great
start culinarily to the trip right
and then we head down the coast and
there's not much maine left after
portland when you're going south but
there is a place called york maine which
based on my limited research was
a very many maine coastline so like
we're talking rocky coast line that has
a little trail that you can walk on a
little little beach there okay we
actually pull up and there's a dude
getting out of the water in a wetsuit i
mean i can't explain to you how
was he cold he was surfing
how cold
it was and how cold i imagined the water
to be but you can't keep a main man down
he's going to surf they're they're used
to it they're rugged
um took a little stroll
again met some more mythical beasts on
the trail and i was like this is
interesting huh because i bought a
t-shirt in maine
and the
and the the girl who sold me the t-shirt
was a mythical beast we go to the
eventide restaurant and somebody in the
back is a mythical beast we stop
uh to take a trail on in maine
and we meet like two sets of mythical
beasts one whole family of mythical
beasts on the trail and i'm like well
you know i haven't been out in in
in this way in other parts of the
country
literally in years right
because i pretty much have been in north
carolina is the only place i've been
and your food network shows not even now
and the food network show's not even out
and i always use i use this collectively
as a little bit of
it's always a nice little check-in to be
like people still people still care
people still watching this show people
still listening to this podcast
and
the beginning of the trip was showing a
lot of promise that yes people are still
engaged link just so you know i've been
i've gone out i've done a report people
are still watching the show people still
know who we are did they ask about me uh
yes i got a number of where's link and i
was like i don't have you know he's not
currently being geo-tracked by me so i
don't know
so we drive to boston
i was in north carolina
by the way yeah well i didn't want to
give up your location
uh i felt like we needed to do something
historical again this was a little bit
of an obligation type thing we're going
to be going through boston and
philadelphia we're going through like
where the country
you know started as we consider the
united states where things were kind of
getting going
and
lock and i don't care a whole lot about
that history to be completely honest
with you neither one of you were up for
it but you did it anyway no it was like
i can take a little bit but i'm not
gonna like go on the whole freedom trail
you know what i'm saying like there's a
place there's like a two mile stretch in
boston
that you can just walk and there's all
these historical things and you can read
plaques and stuff like that and it was
like ah let's just go what's the coolest
thing on this paul revere's house yeah
so we went into paul rivera's house it's
like six bucks to walk around
this thing hasn't changed much i felt
very historical
we read all the plaques the british are
coming we considered finnish are coming
yeah uh we we read about paul revere
and uh we felt like we had done our duty
and then we went uh we were actually all
right all right what are we gonna eat
next exactly well so i didn't know this
about boston because you and i have been
to boston a couple of times but we
haven't spent a lot of time there and
we're usually there like under someone
else's guidance right
yeah and so
i was expecting more seafood in boston
but apparently the north end of boston
is essentially a little italy and has
some of the best italian food that you
can find
so i was like well i'm kind of in the
mood for that and plus we wanted to
watch another one of the basketball
games because the basketball games were
continuing to happen throughout an
italian bar
we did we went to an italian restaurant
that had a bar sat at the bar in eight
i drank a little bit
and we watched one of the basketball
games um
and then we went to another place i
can't remember we had some really good
italian food
uh but we had to leave boston and get to
rhode island i never this is one of the
states i was checking off you know
marking off of the list that i've never
been to
didn't realize until relatively recently
that it is not an island oh god did you
think rhode island was an island
i think i'm
it's kind of when you make it like
florida you look at that part of the map
like a peninsula
so i guess it's not even really a
peninsula i i would have said sure it's
an island well this is the deal there is
an island
called rhode island that they call
something else that is a big island that
is right there and i think when most
just amateur
map people
like me look at a map they see an island
up there and they're like that's rhode
island really really small you can walk
across it in a day but no it's bigger
than that and it's not an island
so we stayed in providence
and uh you didn't go to the island the
proper
we didn't really have time because we
had uh a very packed agenda the next day
okay so because that was main day and
boston day and then it was basically
like all we're going to do is sleep and
roll in rhode island so stayed in
providence i got to say i don't feel
like i fully experienced your providence
i was inside you for a very small amount
of time
but nothing happened it wasn't exciting
you know what i'm saying nothing
happened um i was just inside and then i
pulled out real fast
but what i did have is a donut because
it seemed like
they were very proud of their donuts
in that part of the country they tend to
be very proud of their donuts
yeah and i had a very good donut and a
very good latte that was the thing every
single day loch and i were like where
are we going to get that latte he loves
lattes i love lattes
not coffee
lattes yes we are fully angelino okay
and i didn't think latte was angelino
it's just a lot of milk so i like a
latte
yeah but it's a little fruit fruit let's
just be honest okay cowboys drink black
coffee you you see clint eastwood
showing up
you know at the campfire and asking for
a live stream
yeah i mean come on get with the program
here it's a little froof room
but i i unashamedly enjoy it but you got
to get make sure you get a good one so
we would look up and where's the best
place for a latte this place happened to
have donuts food really
directed your food was i was like we
both really like to eat
and we both really like lattes
and so we're gonna be happy if you're if
you're well fed you're going to be happy
even if you don't get to do some
attraction that you thought you wanted
to do
rather i better be for well-fed than to
be well entertained with your eyes i
think i would do the same thing
i'm not much of a sightseeing person
especially when when there's an
itinerary yeah i i i think i would
prioritize this well too and i
it's funny both of these trips have
done something to me
got me to a place i have a tendency and
i know you have the same tendency to be
like am i really enjoying this as much
as i should did i
make the best decision about where we
went did i stop at the right places what
did i miss did i do enough research
are we having as good of time as we
should be having right now they call
that fomo i constantly ask myself that
question in fact lock and i had a really
great conversation as we were walking on
the main coastline i was talking about
how i'm having a great time this is
beautiful but i just want to like like
and i really we connect a lot and we've
connected a lot this year which is
interesting because we had that
conversation on air biscuits about what
to do in his last year and like these
two trips have like
our friendship has really blossomed
that's cool and we had this conversation
i was telling him about this i was like
man we're having we're in this place
we're doing this amazing thing and i'm
kind of thinking about what else we
could be seeing and what am i missing
and i had to like i made a decision on
that first day in maine to sort of let
go of that and be like whatever i'm
experiencing is what i'm supposed to be
experiencing and so i didn't have that
fomo the rest of the trip
that's good that's very good right but
we uh
we needed to get to yale now i want to
be clear locke is he may be interested
in yale but uh he's not yale material
so so
we're he's not going to yale uh but one
of his really good friends is okay and
so he uh
we wanted to see him we wanted to stop
and see his buddy ray who we've known
for
years and we were like raise it yale
i've always wanted to see yale lock
really wants to to see yale to see what
he's not ever going to experience
um and you know just to see like an ivy
league school
um
and i
you know and i i always i have this like
this visions in my in my mind of what a
northeast like ivy league school looks
like i've never been to harvard never
been to yale
i've been texting with ray
um
we were on a little group thread and i
was planning the trip and i was like hey
what's your schedule on so and so date
that we're coming through
and he was a little slow to respond
and then we kind of worked it out he's
like oh i've got class that day but i'll
be able to like get lunch with you guys
you know and i was like okay well i'll
plant it so that we're coming through
around around lunchtime lock and i'll
probably walk around the campus check it
out then we'll get lunch
we'll have lattes and well the latte
already happened and
so
we we arrive in new haven connecticut
which is where yell was which is not
something that i could have told you
um and we park
next to campus and i text ray and i'm
like hey we're here we're going to walk
around a little bit let us know when
you're out of class i'll come get you
and we'll go to this place that we're
going to eat that i had chosen
consulted with him but chosen yeah for
reasons i'll get into
ray was like
what you're here
your text said you would be here
on so and so day a month later
a month later so i was there on like
march 20 something and my text had said
i was going to be on april 20 something
because when i looked at the calendar i
got it wrong
by a month by a whole month oh wow so
was he even
was they able to meet you first of all
let me just tell you that
these circumstances bring
high amounts of shame to me i do not
like to be the guy that makes the
mistake i
hate making mistakes
you don't know your months dude and i
just beat myself up beat myself up over
it so i was like dang it what what is
wrong with me like
how did i screw this up and
but then he immediately is like but we
were there on a monday which was the
same day that we had planned on and so
he was like you know what what a welcome
surprise my schedule's the same as it
was gonna be
i'll text you when i'm out of class
totally fine
so i felt great
um
so we meet ray and it turns out that uh
he said what a welcome surprise what are
we gonna yell yeah since he's been at
yale he's welcome he's using terms like
that right yeah
i think he also used the term um
sparingly one time i didn't use it
sparingly
well one time is pretty sparingly
um no he's always been a well-spoken guy
that's why he's at yale
so uh he uh
i have been told by the guy that i knew
from from maine but also from a little
research that new haven connecticut is
known best for its
pizza in fact considered to have what
might be the best pizza in the nation
and specifically is it a different style
um isn't the how do you say that
uh neapolitan yeah i'd say it that way
uh it's that style so a pizza about that
big that they kind of put into you know
wood fire oven and apparently this
freight plays frank pepe's
pepes
pepe's pace
pay pays um is supposed to be great in
fact has been voted the number one pizza
place in the nation by some publications
so i was very excited about this were
they expecting you next month
uh
no i didn't make a reservation
thankfully because i would have been a
month off uh and it's a little bit of
like a hole in the wall kind of outside
outside of the main part of town
situation and there's another place
that's supposed to be his competitor
that i didn't seem like it was as good
based on what i saw
anyway had a good meal i wouldn't say
it's the best pizza i've ever had i'm
sorry new haven it was very very good i
did get a t-shirt okay it was good
enough to get the t-shirt
but
once you get to a certain level of pizza
it's sort of like how do you how do you
go any further you know what i mean okay
i get that but
interesting thing that happened at yale
so as i explained to you
a second ago
was getting recognized
a fair amount
um
got recognized at the paul revere house
in in boston right like okay i'm like
okay this is coming down from the the
east coast there's people in the
northeast who are mythical beasts it
makes me feel good
but when we get to yale we get out of
the car and we start walking and the
students are getting out of class and
there's just hundreds of students and i
turn a lock and i say
now like i don't think i'm going to get
recognized at yale i was like these
students are too busy and too smart for
us i mean i'm just going to be honest
with you oh you're throwing the myth i'm
not doing that listen i i just think
that if you're at this institution
you're just studying a whole lot and
you're thinking about things on such a
high level that i'm sorry to say
i just don't consider what we bring to
the table in terms of entertainment to
be high brow link i mean at times we may
sound smart
but it's a charade
and and i think that uh
i'm not saying that the mythical beasts
are stupid
by any means i'm just saying that
you know when we're getting to like the
point one percent smartest people on the
planet
i just think at that point they're just
not watching a lot of youtube videos
it's my guess right
okay that was my theory
my theory proved correct i walked
past hundreds of students pouring out of
classrooms
nobody says a thing
i felt good that i had been right in my
prediction a little bit bad that i had
been right in my prediction
so
these people are
they're
preoccupied
they don't have time for entertainment
but
so we spend the again a couple of hours
between we walked around uh like the way
that they do it is they live in these
colleges there's multiple colleges on a
campus it's very much designed in the
way like when i went to oxford
a while back when i was in london yeah
when i was in england it's it's
you could totally tell they were like we
did it this way over here and now we're
gonna come over here and do these ivy
these schools in exactly the same way so
we like walk through the iron doors i
mean first of all it's the campus is
just
you you've been on like duke's campus
before which has this old school feel
it's like that
on steroids
and the college is you're like you this
is where you live in this little you
have this little courtyard and you walk
through this iron gate and there's
medieval medieval stonework yeah all
this stonework incredible stonework and
then he like passes by the skull and
bones like house oh really this is where
they this is their meeting house or
whatever but again no one's recognized
me
and we finish up we had lunch with ray
we
say our goodbyes to ray and then we
start walking to the car
um
and
we're we are
then a whole group of el students says
surprise we didn't know who you were 50
yards from the car
lock turns to me he's like
dad
i actually didn't believe you but you
were right
no one at yale recognized you the moment
the moment he finishes the sentence
i hear
gratin red from rattling holy
holy oh wow that's a very sophisticated
response
and there's a guy
who uh i think he recognized me
uh a little a little bit and can
continue to just be like man holy
rhett from rhett link um so it was just
like
the enthusiasm made up for the
if you know i could get recognized by no
one at yale and to have one guy say holy
when he recognizes me right passionately
it just it changed my whole view of yale
it changed my whole view of the ivy
league system there's hope yeah there's
hope for us
uh
i will continue telling you uh the story
there's a lot more cities there's a lot
more stories on the way
uh but we do want to talk about inside
east with rhett link our television show
i mean it's been a while since we had a
television show yes we do this about
every 10 years so
yeah we go behind the scenes we get
unfettered access well we're kind of
fettered there's people there who are
watching us but we go to like test
kitchens we go to headquarters of your
favorite eateries food places
so i mean chipotle
cheesecake factory we also went to a
cool house
an amazing
ice cream shop
that's i'll call it syndicated beyond
meat we're the first people to ever get
access to film behind the scenes at
beyond meat which is really cool so
we learned a lot
and um
had a lot of fun
so it's this interesting mix of
comedy and f and food experience and
access that creates inside eats with
bretton link
10 30 p.m food network same time it's
launched on discovery plus
um the extended versions
are on discovery plus yeah so check it
out we've been saying things like
bonus footage but that makes you think
that you're going to like watch click on
something else and it's like no the
episodes are longer and have things that
we had to cut out to get to the 22.
extended versions is it right it's the
right way yeah so check it out
we're on food network we're doing it
and i think and we're we're just being
us man just being us man eating stuff
having a great time
check it out inside eats okay so left
new haven uh the plan is to head to new
york and look at a school in new york
that lock is interesting oh wow yeah
because that that
i was picturing rhode island in
connecticut south of new york state nope
i don't know why
it is funny how the geography sort of
gets jumbled up
is in your mind as you're driving
through it the other thing that you
realize is that
unlike any place that i've ever lived
the concentration of population in major
cities is so high so much higher in the
northeast than anywhere else
like once you get to like north carolina
you're going to be driving a while
before you get to a major metropolitan
area but when you're up there you're
going to go from
like
portland
to
to
boston to providence to
new haven to new york to philly to
baltimore to east like there's just a
bunch of big cities right there next to
each other because it's where it all
started you know how long were you in
new york city so we get to new york in
the afternoon and you know we're the
mclaughlins so we did not plan any
official tours
let me just say your song at new york
city not new york state new york city
you should plan official college tours
i'll explain it in a second um
if you're gonna do if you're gonna
because
with this campus in particular it's
pretty secure campus
and when we tried to just walk into it
we were stopped by security guard he was
like you can't just walk in here i was
like well he's been accepted here and
he's just looking no i mean no you can't
do that has to be like an official thing
and i was like okay so we ended up
uh traveling into man scaling a wall
traveling into manhattan and spending
the night and then setting up a tour for
the next day to to drive back out of the
city to go to this school for an
official tour so that was a little bit
of a hiccup in our travel schedule but
it didn't really matter so that no i'll
tell you about that in a second but that
night
we go to
lower east side new york which just
happens to be where we end up staying
every time we go to new york yeah which
is a great spot really high
concentration of great restaurants and
stuff when you have an 18 year old with
you you can't go into bars and you can't
like go into comedy clubs there's a lot
of things that you can't do when you
have somebody under 21. i was like oh
this is interesting i haven't thought
about this but what you can do is go to
restaurants so we like
did the whole food tourish type thing
where you go to a restaurant
and you just get a couple of things and
you leave and you go to another
restaurant and get a couple of things i
just i
this style of vacation has really like
opened a whole world to me this road
trip vacation where you just drop into a
city and eat a couple of things at a few
different restaurants
it might be my new way of vacationing
it's just
i don't necessarily mean
a full like
top of the nation to the bottom of the
nation road trip but it might be like
i'm gonna land in one state it's been a
couple of days in this place and i'm
gonna go to this other state in this
other city like i this dual city thing
is i'm definitely floating this idea
with you you're getting ready for europe
then that's how you can exactly
um
so
we spend some time in manhattan have
some great food then we go back we do
the official tour which was illuminating
because we've done some unofficial tours
but like when you can like get into the
buildings and stuff and like
you don't have to like wait till a
student like opens the door and then
like run in behind them it's it's much
better
and you also get to ask questions to
people who have experienced at this
college okay yeah so i was like oh man
like this is this is
lesson learned for shepard is what i
kept telling like i was like okay well
me and shepard do this
i'm gonna do it better than i did it
with you okay uh and you don't have to
have you don't have to do what i did if
you have a kid do official tours you're
probably already thinking that now i
knew i wanted to drive to philadelphia
and again
we were going to go to pat's in geno's
and eat a cheesesteak from both places
oh both places so
the thing was to take lock to this place
where i've got this experience from
making this video in 2008 yeah
uh on the alka seltzer great american
road trip
and i was like we're gonna taste these
cheese steaks and then we're i'm you're
going to help me determine which one's
the best and then we're going to get the
t-shirt from the place that we think has
got the best cheesesteak but
i hear a buck coming
so we go to gino's first okay and
the flashy one flashy orange
color you know he's the one that's like
the big personality bit of a
controversial character as well
uh i think he had a sign on the door for
years that was just like if you can't
order in english don't order it all or
something like that
i think it's been taken down
but i was like okay but these are the
these are the classic cheese take places
we're going to get one from both of them
we get up to gino's and immediately the
guys who are cooking the steaks back
there who are not old enough to have
worked there since 2008. these guys are
in their 20s yeah or like
rhett
read from the video from the video yeah
oh wow they all see the video so it's
not like rhett from mythical morning
it's just like this video apparently is
something that
if you work at pasadena's you you've
seen this video
and so then they were like he knows
what's up he came back to the right
place and i wasn't about to say i'm
going to pass right after that
so we get one cheesesteak now first of
all lock's a little bit picky okay
and
i kind of knew this was going to be a
little bit difficult for him because i
was like the way that they suggest you
order it is with cheese whiz and he was
like dad i can't eat something with
cheese was on it like he just won't do
it
and so i was like all right well you're
probably right let's get the one with
provolone it was just better anyway
right that's what i thought so we get
like
you know you have a special way you have
to order it they're not as strict at
geno's as they are at pat's about saying
and all in the right order or whatever
uh but we get it and we split it and we
eat it
and
first thing i'm struck with is like this
is not that great let's gonna be honest
with you i'm like i've had a lot of
great cheesesteaks and i've had a lot of
good sandwiches and i was just like yeah
this is just
it's just just not that great
but it's pretty good but it's not if i
made a cheesesteak at home if i threw
something together with some good bread
and some cheesesteak meat like i'd be
getting pretty close to this right
and lock's like it's yeah it's good it's
oh it's pretty good
so then we go to pat's
and i tried to i went around the back to
try to i didn't want them to see me just
go over to pets i felt a little
self-conscious
yeah because because they had ability
you chose the right place because you
can see them from each other yeah oh
yeah because they're right they're two
two adjacent corners yeah so we go over
to pat's
and our first thing i do is i order from
the wrong window i can [ __ ] because
there's a drink and everything else
window and there's a cheesesteak window
and there's a very particular way and
you're supposed to say it in order it's
kind of a little bit of a i mean at this
point it's a pain it's it's part of the
like the test the vibe
they make this thing with provolone i
got to be honest with you like the pro
genos they put the provolone and the
meat together and it kind of melted
it past they put the provolone on after
they put the meat on there and it was
just like not melted into the meat
and then good either we sit down lock
takes one bite and spits it out oh my
gosh and i take a bite i'm like oh gosh
this is
this is
actively bad oh my god this is active i
remember pat's being better that's what
i thought
i'm just saying again you can't john
downhill man
no i have a theory and i have a
conclusion i have three conclusions i
came to on this trip and one of them is
about passing okay
my theory is now the thing that you see
all on pat's all on the advertising is
about how they're the first place
they're the guys who invented
cheesesteaks
the original that's what it says all
over and there's like all these
different fonts are like written many
different times in many different ways
if you've been doing something the same
way
for i don't know 50 years well
the american palette has
been transformed
significantly and people are eating
better and better things as locke
said and i wholeheartedly agree with him
he's like dad
the big kahuna from jersey mike's is
like
five times as good as either of these
sandwiches
and i was like you are 100 right
the bread is better the meat is better
the cheese is better the way they do it
is better
if you're just doing something to doing
it the same to do it the same way and
let me just tell you
no crowds at either place i didn't have
to wait at either place i bet it's only
tourists too
so here's my conclusion and i hate to
throw it listen i'm a fan of what you've
done i'm a fan of the tradition i went
there i purchased the steak i did not
get a t-shirt from either place i didn't
feel like either place stood up to it oh
met the standard
my challenge my conclusion
is that
one of the places passing genos if they
actually want to end the cheesesteak
wars once and for all
they need to publicly admit that it's
time to change and they need to reinvent
their cheesesteak and do it in a way
that reflects the evolution of the
modern palette
and they need to bring out a new
cheesesteak and be like listen we did it
the same way for 50 years and now we're
doing it the right way and all of a
sudden the other place will be leveled
so the other place will never recover
if you got the kahunas or the cajones
to do it
do it that's that's my conclusion when i
was in north carolina we went to highway
55 formerly known as andy's cheesesteaks
when we were growing up there
uh got some new facilities next to the
bojangles and lillian it's better that
is a good cheese steak it's better it's
better than pasta oh yeah
i came to two other conclusions that
i'll fold into this because the other
one happened on the same day
i had noticed by this point that there
were multiple times when we needed to
use the restroom
okay
when you're traveling you need to use
the restroom and when you're in a city
you g
there's no public restrooms there's no
public restrooms and there's so few
public restrooms in america but you're
always eating at a restaurant if passing
gino's they don't have a bathroom
we had to piss
we've been drinking lattes man
big lattes
eating cheese steaks drinking pepsi or
whatever it was
i think i know where you're going with
this i got a piss man
and then we start talking about like i
mean i had to piss so bad am i gonna
find a place to piss
and relax like you can't do that because
you don't want to get arrested for
public urination that would be bad it'll
be bad look
you know i would love that
for you and then i was like i actually
think i could live this one down i think
this might be good pr for me because
it's not real serious but i was like
you're right
so we actually had to do this in new
haven and then we had to do it again
where you go into a place and you
purchase something just in order to use
the restroom so in new haven we went to
a subway and got a cookie
so we could use the restroom that hurts
and in philly we went into a titan
restaurant and i asked for one garlic
knot apparently that is that's that is
you can't get one garlic now that gave
me four
so
four garlic knots or one cookie equals
one urination i want two units special
yeah
and we did eat the cookie and we did eat
all four garlic knots because why not
you've got him there and then i came to
a conclusion i was like
this didn't happen to me when i was in
australia because everywhere you go in
australia
there is a toilet that you can put a
coin in to access a public toilet that
requires
a little bit of money to use
paid public restrooms now whether
they're free and when they're subsidized
or whether they're paid
america needs more restrooms they need
more public restrooms in cities i just
don't i don't they didn't turn all of
the defunct
pay phones into
little walk-in closets i mean remember
in amsterdam you'd walk around this like
spiral thing to the center
and then you would pee
and it would and
from your shoulders up as a six foot
tall person from my shoulders up
i was just i was just looking at the
landscape
yeah at the urban landscape yeah people
were p i could make eye contact with
people while i was peeing no i don't
like that but you could not you couldn't
see me peeing well you could see my face
you might have seen me and tell that i
was playing i don't know and you could
also see my shoes and some of them i
think
and i think there was like a toilet
there but yeah and there was no it was
just like a there was no door it was
just like kind of like a snail shell
what ends up happening i love that what
ends up happening in american cities and
i'm sure this happens around the world
but you know homelessness is a big issue
in american cities and it's only gotten
worse
through the pandemic so you've got these
these unhoused people who
got to use the bathroom somewhere and so
but these restaurants are like i don't
want this homeless person coming in here
and messing up my bathroom and so
you got to purchase something to use the
bathroom customers only and then it
creates
situations where where the homeless
people use in the bathroom sometimes on
the street you know in la there's like
they'll bling like a porta potty or
something like that out there but i
thought you were going to say that you
were going to get like a go girl like
one of those things well for oh i have
one for girls i didn't bring it though
it
it works in such a way that i haven't
had
a wide mouth
um i mean it's i mean
i'm not bragging you have a p now g no i
have a thing that is it's glows in the
dark i i talked about this before
it's a it's a glow-in-the-dark thing
with a handle that you can pee in during
the night while camping i love that i
should have just brought should have
brought that but you could
have one per person yeah but you could
have but you could have bought like a
a big container well here's the other
thing the third conclusion something you
need the third conclusion i came to
because i love these things is
one of the things they have in the
northeast
is these travel centers you know about
the travel center yeah like a truck stop
but it's a gas station it's a it's a
rest stop
that has
a whole it has it has multiple things it
has it is a gas station or a convenience
store yeah it is a
electric car charging station
and
it is a food court with like a starbucks
and a mcdonald's and a kfc multiple
plate and then a bunch of places to sit
and of course really nice very large
very clean bathrooms
it's like a capitalistic rest stop and i
just got to say we need more of these in
the united states i i it's just
because this is the platform you're
running on
coin-operated toilets and travel centers
everywhere it's just it's such a missed
opportunity like rest stops are okay but
like the travel centers just make you
feel so american
okay well i mean go as long as you want
but we're still in new york state oh
yeah yeah
well as you know what the pacing of my
conversation goes with the concentration
of metro areas which again is very very
cluttered at the top of the country okay
so from there we drove i guess we were
in philly we drove to washington dc to
spend the night oh um
this may have been the highlight okay
now let me just say i wasn't expecting
dc to be the highlight
and you know i've been to dc many times
and i've seen all the monuments and the
stuff that you see and it's just like
it's always kind of cool but it's not
like i can't guess why dc well i'm going
to blow your mind it has to be the food
obviously it's all you did well so
uh washington dc has great ethiopian
food because there's a very large
ethiopian population really known for
some of it some great ethiopian food so
we picked like the best place i knew
this is going to be a little bit of a
stretch for locke
because again he's picky and picky
people don't like to venture out into
places like ethiopian food i think i
would like ethiopian food um so it's
essentially a bunch of meats and
vegetables and stuff put on this big
pancake and then you take another piece
of the pancake and you pick it up and
eat it
um it's exquisite i love it but it's the
kind of thing that i don't want to i
don't want to do it all the time
and it was like satisfying great
whatever
well we had some plans for the next day
i originally planned that we were going
to wake up early and go basically see
the monuments right we stayed
in a hotel pretty near the mall the
washington the the the mall and
he thought that was until i clarified he
thought that was like a mall mall
no this is not a mall sun we're not
shopping
this is a place where all the monuments
are
but then i'm looking it's like 10
o'clock at night after we finished we
had gotten there late we had a late
dinner got some dessert at another place
again we would like go to two different
places that was the mo
and i'm like these monuments are open 24
hours a day and there's lights
that's cool and i was like let's go see
all of them right now in the middle of
the night
that's a good idea so
we took an uber
to the jefferson memorial which is on
like the far side of the tidal basin
which i didn't know that's what it was
called but that's the giant lake there
in the middle that all the monuments are
around
right next to the mall that's the title
base the shallow swimming pool
no no you're thinking about the long
man-made thing that's
directly between the lincoln memorial
and the washington monument i'm talking
a giant lake oh okay
so we go to the jefferson memorial and
there and again it's probably like
10 45 11 p.m at this point there's one
family in the jefferson memorial and
they leave
so we have the entire jefferson memorial
to ourselves
and i never what are you gonna do with
it deface it no we were like talking
about how like there's all these like
cameras and oh there's cops around
not that we actually wanted to deface it
but i've only ever seen this stuff
when there's a bunch of other people and
it's like hot and it was like cold it
was like
kind of uncomfortably cold
and that made the crowds really low you
were like why am i going to go in the
middle of night when it's cold
but these things are designed to be seen
at night the lighting is incredible and
there's like this solemn sort of feel
and i was like
this is going to be amazing so we go
uh clockwise around the whole thing
so we stop so like jefferson memorial
and then there's like there's other
stuff that i had never really seen
before like the f there's a whole fdr
section and then there's a whole mlk
section which is amazing i think that
might be the most recent that's newer
yeah
and then
going around hitting the lincoln the
lincoln memorial which there was
probably like 10 people there like you
can't get the lincoln memorial to
yourself they're just it's just too
popular but like
we like said it we stood up there on the
stage and we had just seen
the martin luther king memorial and then
we go stand exactly where he stood when
he gave his speech and we're just
talking about like when he gave this
speech like if you could have told him
like listen you're going to be
remembered as this great man and a
matter of fact there's going to be like
a 40-foot statue of you over here almost
within eye shot
and you're going to be killed for saying
these things you know by the government
most likely you know what i'm saying
it's like
the
it was it was just kind of surreal
and lock and i were like having really
great conversation about a lot of things
but there was a i got this weird
feeling of i'm gonna use the term
i'm gonna use the term patriotism but
let me contextualize that
you know our country is so
divided like so like viciously divided
right now right yeah um and like people
on both sides of the argument think that
the people on the other side are
legitimately evil right like that's the
point that we've gotten to like we've
gotten so polarized that we think that
the other group of americans is evil
and
there was something about like being
there at this time and seeing these and
listen our country is just riddled with
it's it's a complex complicated history
like i said the fact that you've got
this giant statue of mlk right next to
the place where he spoke and then like
we know for a fact that the fbi didn't
want him to be alive you know
and so we know that our
there's so much complex history
but something about being there at night
seeing these things that like
we did this thing we started this
country and it's supposedly built on
this principle of the equality of all
people
uh and we put these things in this giant
grassy area to like symbolize this and
it was just there was just something
kind of moving about it and strangely
like the sense of hope that like
obviously like looking at the washington
monument it isn't like the fact that we
can build this giant obelisk obelisk
into the sky means we're going to get
through this but
naively maybe is kind of this is what it
made me feel i was like all right we're
going to get through this and this big
giant ass thing is going to still be in
the air
but wow aside from work aside from my
yeah the propaganda i told like i was
like the propaganda is working very well
for this guy like i'm a very i'm very
susceptible to marketing but the whole
thing is just marketing america and i
was like you got me like i believe in
this principle equality for all people
let's make it happen let's come together
and make it happen
um but regardless of your political
affiliation and and
what you think about what i just said
let me just tell you
go see him at night go see those
monuments at night it's just
awesome locked told it told me that it
was a highlight of the trip for him
he had no idea that was even going to
happen
it's like you're going up to each one
and you're like where is the food in
this one okay so the distance traveled
each day is about to increase
um
we drove to charlottesville virginia
my nephew like's cousin goes to uva we
took a little tour of uva cavaliers uh
what a beautiful campus by the way i
love college campuses i love the idea of
college campuses college was a great
experience for me
uh and i love just that just like this
the city kind of just exists
for this university that's been here
forever
we went to edgar allan poe's dorm room
because he went to uva and they still
have it like preserved in the way that
he would have had it when he was there
and you can like look the door is glass
and you can look into it
um
met
several mythical beasts in the
at uva
then we continued on down we picked
actually picked up uh
eli our nephew
brought him with us in north carolina he
needed a ride okay uh so we took him to
north carolina
we met the the family you know
my family
my parents and my brother and his family
uh all hung out at the new
cabin
uh that we got in north carolina
and we also picked up shepard to now
take shepherd all the way to miami so
it's three mclaughlins now that was a
plan to pick up shepard leave jesse in
north carolina she's like doing some
design work there she's going to like
the high point
furniture thing oh just she's like
living her best life in high point and
then shepard so shepherd's coming with
you
yeah and i told the boys that first stop
is the latte well yeah of course
so after the lattes but the the second
stop
is
not the but a
creation museum what
uh-huh
yes sir thank you to roadtrippers.com
again i use that service again still
paying for it so you must have gone
nobody reached out to give it to me for
free
you left north carolina and you went to
where where is a creation music southern
pines
southern pines north carolina yes
so you the creation museum the ken ham
answers in genesis creation museum in
kentucky that has a full scale noah's
ark i haven't been there i would love to
go
i love this kind of thing
i don't know the southern part sidebar
if you know my story
i used to be a christian i am no longer
a christian one of the reasons i'm not
is some conclusions i came to about the
historicity of the bible
but
creationists
and hardcore creationists like young
earth creationists
believe
and this isn't all christians
it's a fair amount but not all
um
believe that everything you read in the
bible is true and noah's art was a real
thing and adam and eve were a real thing
evolution didn't happen people true
literally yeah true literally
it is a literal historical account right
and so when i heard there was a creation
museum in southern pines which have you
been to southern pines
uh it's where i mean there's there's a
golf course there that's really nice so
i saw another near pinehurst where
pineapple is some of the best golf in
the world
uh southern pines is true to its name a
bunch of pine trees and of like this
very historic quaint town
um
what is that the creation museum there
well the creation museum is in a
christian that's the name of the sign
the sign says
the christian bookstore
that's the name of the place it's inside
a bookstore so you go into the bookstore
and then immediately down into the left
there's steps that go down and you can
obviously tell you're entering into like
what feels like
a southern rainforest cafe kind of vibe
because essentially it was this pastor
who has since
died
but they've kept it alive
they've kept the museum alive
it is basically a collection of
taxidermy
of everything you can imagine
what
and also a bunch of tools so it's the
creation museum and the tool museum
and it shows up on like roadside
attraction type stuff because it's so
quirky quirky what this these are just
normal animals
uh there's like a north carolina section
which is like everything that you can
kill in north carolina there's there on
display but there's also just like
mostly american things so it's just like
look at all these god made this animal
look god made this animal but then
there's little exhibits like
pretty early on there is a cabinet that
is a glass cabinet and there is nothing
inside of the cabinet and on the top it
says inside this cabinet
is all the credible evidence for
evolution so it's things like that but
there was a little snake with an apple
inside the cabinet which was like satan
the serpent inside the cap
now this guy was like serious about all
this like he didn't necessarily have a
sense of humor about any of this and i
didn't know how the people who currently
run the christian bookstore were going
to feel about this because i'm obviously
coming in there as a guy who's like i
disagree with everything that you're
talking about but wild man but i like
i'm fascinated by this mentality and i
and i understand it because i've known
so many people who believe this that
like this would be a fun thing for us to
do and i'm not going in there to make
fun of them to their face i mean
obviously we're going in there and be
like what this is crazy we're kind of
laughing
but i'm not going to laugh in their face
and i was also like
you know how much does it cost and they
were like whatever you think it's worth
yeah
and so i did drop 20 bucks into the
donation thing i'm like i'm gonna come
here and i'm and i'm you know i'm gonna
send a lot of people to you guys because
if you're in southern pines go to the
christian bookstore look at the creation
museum it's fascinating
there's a whole section
it's very it's kind of crazy how much
crap this guy
collected
he collected these tools that i didn't
even ever really figure out what it was
they looked like levels he was really
like he's got all these old certain type
of tool
like found
like antiques but a whole bunch of the
same thing like hundreds of the same
thing i don't even know what this thing
is i'm afraid to ask
but you're not a placard reader but
there is a section
where let you go down a little hallway
and come to this like glass case
and it'll say
these are the things these are the other
gods that the world worships
and it'll be like
um
country music what
and then it'll be like a guy on the
front of a muscle magazine
or like a woman but not a woman in a
bikini but like suggesting like these
are the other things but then mixed in
with the country music
muscles and sexiness but you know the
worldly pleasures but mixed in
indiscriminately where the worldly
pleasures is like
something that represents like an
african tribal religion
like so like other religions like
buddhism
so like
again
you got to understand i totally
understand this way of thinking i used
to kind of think this way growing up you
thought that all these other religions
were essentially like
satanic expressions of things they
weren't like somebody's like heritage
and the same type of thing that you had
done and come up with your own deal yeah
you thought that they were wrong and you
were right and so you could put them
along with all these other vices like
worrying too much about your body or
caring too much about food or caring too
much about music
and the boys were fascinated they were
just like what i don't they they could
they couldn't process it they were like
i don't understand what he's saying i'm
like no well let me understand he's
saying that everything outside of god
and jesus as you understood in a very
particular interpretation of the bible
everything outside of that is wrong
that's what this guy thought and that's
what a lot of people still do think it's
the source of a lot of strife and you
gave him twenty dollars and i gave him
twenty dollars right uh so we saw the
creation museum highly recommend it and
then we were on our way to florence
south carolina to stop at this
hole in the wall barbecue place
that i had read about
but little did i know that kind of
coming from southern pines and getting
to florence south carolina we were going
to go right past
south of the border this was an
unintended stop
so if you've ever been on i-95 going
from north carolina to south carolina
you got sucked in huh you see well you
can't not stop there when you're on a
road trip with your kids yeah
now
you see all the signs that every mile
there's a billboard let me just i'm just
going to go up and
definitely
a
highly racist
stereotype of a mexican man named pedro
who wears a giant sombrero and has a
mustache and is welcoming you to south
carolina as if you're passing from
america to mexico it was somebody's
grand idea many many decades ago to like
have this mexican themed playland
there's a motel there there's a pup pup
place there there's a giant pedro with a
giant sombrero tower that you can go
into yeah
so we stopped there how is it still it's
not doing well man i mean it's
we literally were inside the souvenir
shop and the power went out like it just
the whole place just went black
i guess they shut down while we're here
and we witnessed the end of south of the
border but the boys again
you know they're growing up in much more
uh uh informed times than we did and so
like they're just like dad this is like
so racist
i'm like yes son i did not realize that
when i was your age but you're yeah
you've been educated differently so we
decided to not get a t-shirt i was like
i you know okay yeah i don't
i don't really want to play into this
whole whole thing
um but it's still there and it's become
a little bit of an artifact
yeah in and of itself
uh but we were gonna go to this
hole-in-the-wall barbecue place
now i just heard about this place i'm
actually
i'm torn
with with mentioning it
because i don't it was the barbecue was
very very good um
but the guy is like
so politically like he's he's really
just set himself up his his barbecue
place has become like a political
statement
oh um
so you can find it if you want to you
don't have to do too much research but
i won't give them the free advertising
but the barbecue was
impeccable
really
um mustard based it wasn't so mustard
base is kind of isolated more to the
columbia area and we weren't going
through colombia and so i was they had a
mustard base that you could put on
things that we did kind of get
but
the barbecue we got pulled pork
sandwiches and they were pre-sauced but
sauced in a good way and just in
pretty finely chopped so very similar to
north carolina that there's like it's
not pulled pork it's chopped pork
which is not my preference if i'm doing
it myself yeah neither uh
i like to make whatever i'm eating in
the moment my preference because i have
a lot better time with it
so
and i did that and it was exquisite it
was great
it's a food truck that is next to a
dining
facility like a like a dining room
on just like this random road like a
shelter
no it's like you could have put the
restaurant in here but you didn't
because you want to drive it over
there's a pool table in the middle of it
and fox news was on on the television
and then we set we all purposely set
right next to because we're the only
ones in there
a giant picture of donald trump the
picture was so big what that when you're
next to it it was like you couldn't even
tell you're so pixelated
like you could see that they had printed
this thing out and they did not have a
picture that was large enough the
resolution of the trump picture wasn't
large enough for this sign
but it says it's got republican with a
box democrat with a checkbox and then
trump with the check box and has checked
trump and hasn't checked republican or
democrat wow so that's the statement
that this guy's making and there's a lot
of other
questionable paraphernalia and some
stuff on the wall that kind of thing but
the thing is is that
that is what the south is in a lot of
ways right like if you get outside of
the cities you that's what you you
that's the mentality that you're going
to run into into a lot of the people and
i was just basically just telling the
boys i'm like this is man this is where
i come from like this is
our background
and this is the barbecue that they make
and i'm not gonna just not go there
you know because they've identified with
this racist soul
but you know
it was a little bit of an eye-opening
experience but they also kind of loved
it in a sense not loved what that dude
stands for and what the mentality that
those people but it's almost like going
to a foreign place yeah now when you're
when you live in los angeles you don't
get to see
that
you know right and we have the privilege
as a as three white dudes just rolling
through the countryside i'm not worried
about my safety i might get a some side
eye because of my hair or whatever or
the clothes i've got on yeah but i'm not
gonna my life is not in danger i don't
feel unsafe i don't feel like i need to
make sure i'm in my hotel before the sun
goes down right um
which if my skin was a different color i
might feel that way so i recognize the
privilege of being able to like go and
experience these things and almost like
a historian like an observer like a
journalist type way because i can just
come back to
my bubble over here in los angeles not
have to see any of this stuff um
but great barbecue if you happen to
figure out where it is based on what i
just said
uh we stopped in savannah georgia again
now you're talking like you see how
quickly we're moving right yeah so
we go from north carolina we're in north
carolina we lunch in south carolina and
then we're in savannah georgia for the
for dinner
savannah is awesome
so i was actually i know birmingham is
really cool savannah's a different thing
i don't think it's on the ocean
oh yeah we've been university no where
have we been
i've been to savannah before but i don't
know
savannah is
everything that you imagine in terms of
like the deep south with the mossy trees
and the humidity again the temperature
had changed significantly by the time we
get down here to georgia and it's
basically there's a small part of
georgia that's on the coast
and savannah is there there's like
augusta at the top and then savannah
okay
and savannah is old and beautiful
and
it kind of has a little bit of a
charleston meets new orleans kind of
like there's just there's a high
concentration of really great things to
eat
lots of things to do there was like a
music festival going on
there's like soul food southern cooking
restaurants on every single corner right
and of course we didn't know we were
going to be there so i'm not doing any
reservations i'm just like getting there
and maybe there's a place that i've
researched ahead of time but like we
like walking into places the nerves like
we don't have any tables but we did find
a place and i wanted to give you this is
what we ordered just to give you an idea
of the food
um we had
low country mac and cheese with shrimp
and
sausage oh that's what shepard got
i got gumbo and grits
which had everything from gumbo and gr
and cheese grits and lot got country
fried bison
and we just kind of shared it all
country from bison sounds strange
it was like country-style steak but
bison so it was a little bit leaner it
was
incredible
wow um
i highly recommend savannah and that's
when it started to hit me i was like man
me and jesse would have a good time me
and jesse would have a better time to me
and the boys are having here because
it's got that sort of like there's a
little bit of romance in the air it's
supposedly the most haunted city in
america so if you're into like the ghost
tour of it all
there's a bunch of people going around
on like in like
on a ghost tour basically okay
um
just so much history there
um
and then we ended up spending the night
in jacksonville florida so we got all
the way to florida from north carolina
florida again it's like so much more
time past or much more mileage under our
belts in the second half of the trip we
spend the night in jacksonville which by
the way i learned is the largest city by
area
in the continental united states
it's 840 square miles
jacksonville florida is 800. this is
that on the coast square miles
yeah
it's on the east coast of florida at the
very top basically right when you get
into okay yeah i've only passed through
there but i guess it did take a while um
don't feel like i gave jacksonville it's
due we just got to a hotel late at night
and stayed there and then got a latte
and got out
and the latte was pretty good but we
wanted to get to
st augustine oh the oldest city in yeah
so st augustine was my dad's been there
a few times he always talks about how
much he loves it down there the grass
i could totally see your dad loving it
and i gotta say the sort of middle-aged
white dude in me kind of loves it too
like
there's there's something that kind of
draws you there's old houses there's
golf there's grass yeah and you should
see the blades of grass down there the
food the food in all these places you're
getting in just like the best food in
america you know i mean in st augustine
you're kind of getting you're so saint
augustine has like a spanish influence i
learned so much history
i didn't understand how old saint
augustine was
but they basically like built that
mission there like a few decades after
columbus like we're talking about 1530
or something like that they're basically
like this is a town now spaniards and
then i also didn't realize that the
spaniards
owned
florida until the 1800s did you know
that in maybe the late 1800s
it's weird i just didn't understand i
don't
i didn't we didn't take great history
and i didn't pay attention to it well
you got the louisiana purchase yeah that
was when louisiana was purchased we're
talking about florida and then florida
was after that
florida was like one of them the the
last things on the east coast it was the
last thing on the east coast there's a
weird thing that happened with key west
and like the confederacy at some point
and there in the confederacy like
used the fort there at st augustine
which we toured at some point during the
war
i don't know man
it's a cool place there's a lot of
history there
but we were heading to miami and this is
when we started
we actually have been listening to this
ahead of time
but i'm gonna go out i'm gonna break
this out this is my wreck for the week
okay have you heard keith whitley's
miami miami which is his number one song
it's actually you bigger than when you
say it best you say nothing at all
um
i don't know it that well but i know
that he's it sounds like he's saying the
course i mean miami miami miami
is gone or something uh
she he thought she was gonna be gone but
she he's in la the thing is is that he's
in la and she's in miami and he's on
and he's on a plane to miami to see her
and
miami miami loves me after all
it is
an amazing song we listen to a lot of
keith whitley we got into you know joker
he died he died at 34. yeah
um
we'd listen to a lot of keith whitley
the boys were really into keith whitley
i don't know what he died from
locke said alcoholism
when he looked it up on wiki wiki i said
so
we started playing like gratefulness
like you as you're driving towards miami
and you're playing keith whitley it's
just everything is falling into place
much better than the uh
will smith miami route
yeah still a fan but i never liked that
song uh well speaking of songs i i
talked about this in the ama that we did
the other day for the mythical society
but i love to play music that is
regional whether it's you know if we're
heading through a town
so like dolls has a great song saint
augustine at night which we listened to
in the morning because that's when we
were in st augustine we kind of hated
that we weren't there at night but
that's a great song
but we're listening to miami
and then
we're heading into miami
but i had a little surprise planned
and that was to stop
and take a fan boat on the everglades no
really
oh you did that and i did it oh man i'm
so jealous that's the one thing that
i've wanted to do before i die yeah well
i've always wanted now you can die i've
always wanted to be on a fan boat
and so you research you made plans i
made plans okay i almost didn't get
there in time
man
so
the everglades are really big and they
start pretty high but they end on the in
the bottom in miami so you gonna take a
fan boat to miami no so i was basically
there was multiple locations but i was
like i'm gonna drive to the one that's
next to miami
so we're kind of like almost done with
our day and we do this like late
afternoon fan boat ride oh okay
and
uh
shout out to the people at sawgrass
recreational center
they have a little reptile
zoo and then they have the fan boat
rides and there are a few mythical
beasts on the staff there
and
we
i learned some things so we get it's
just the three of us and the and the
dude operating the fan boat how many
seats are on the six
there's three rows of bench seats with
no seat belts oh no there's nothing over
you it's just like a bench
and you just gotta hold on and so lock
and shepard set in front of me and i sat
behind them
it's super loud they get they give you
earplugs oh we didn't wear them because
you know we're in florida um
we'll lose our hearing is fine and then
uh
it's super loud but he's like man he's
been he's lived there all his life and
he's explaining i'm like so
you guys have like you know first of all
we're gonna see some gators he was like
yes we're going to see some gators and
we did and he was like they're active at
this time of the day it's mating season
so we probably saw gators mating 12
alligators
in the wild some really big ones
and then he was explaining no he did we
said have you ever seen a mating was
like just the other day they were there
was they were maintaining when i showed
up and they rolled into the water we
didn't get to see any gator sex uh as
much as i wanted i think they charge
extra if you see that
uh it's like a little retroactive thing
but then like putting a foot into a
gator boot and then
but i'm asking him about i'm just kind
of noticing that it's all
water
i mean
yes there's a hole it's like two feet of
water and there's a whole it looks like
land but i can kind of tell that it's
all water there's no like land
and he's like yeah the bottom half of
the everglades is 600 square miles not
as big as jacksonville
maybe it's 6 000 square miles so that
makes more oh so you didn't have any
like the cypress trees or whatever right
he says that's the land that's going to
have some trees and stuff is further
north and he says and that's where all
those invasive pythons are the ones that
have like taken over the whole
everglades because of people letting
their snakes out their pet snakes he
said i've only seen one down here ever
because they want some land
but then he likes telling us about the
history of this area because there's
also this invasive species of bird he
was like yeah like in the 90s there was
a hurricane and this this bird that's
from another place in the world got out
from some zoo and now they all live
around there and the gators love to eat
them and so like it's just cool it's
cool to see like the ecosystem and how
i guess how screwed up it is there
because it was there was like reeds
everywhere so there was pads we were
going through some obviously natural
sort of canals but there was one really
long straight canal's light now this
isn't natural right he says no actually
a hundred years ago or so the army corps
of engineers decided that they were
going to
drain this and put cows here
and so they put the cows out here and it
was an absolute disaster because it was
like super muddy and they couldn't keep
pumping the water out
and so then they just let it fill back
up
and but one of the things that happened
is there are these little tiny pockets
of land like i'm talking like big enough
to put a house on
that people could come out and claim
so he took us to this island
and there was this island that we didn't
go on like we drove we rode up to it
and it was this house on this island
what
with this giant trump flag
of course
like this is trump country
and this guy has just set up his
he lives out there full time off the
grid no power of course off the grid he
has his own like i think he's got solar
panels or something
but like he's just his land because he
because like you could at some point in
the past you could just claim it and
they got grandfathered in and never had
to pay for it and so he's like yeah this
guy is like 70 years old he's retired he
lives out here
and he he bought a fan boat from us
from the place that i got the hamburgers
and so he has his transportation on his
own fan boat that he goes back and forth
on the lane just living out there
completely i see him getting surrounded
by alligators by the way
surrounded by them
wow
it's just so it's wild man so if if
if we had to do it again you'd be up to
go to like the northern everglades and
because it's a different experience
yeah where the where the woods are
yeah i mean i'd also do that again i
mean
i i don't know i may be going back to
miami a lot lock hasn't made a decision
about school but that was the final
destination was to tour the school and
he's interested in miami which we which
we toured and it was beautiful
uh but the last piece of the trip here
is so we
oh
that night
we go
uh we went to
miami beach which again if you remember
the geography of miami there's a pretty
giant downtown that's on the coast right
and then there's an island that is out
from the coast which is where the real
beach is and that's like where we stayed
at the fontainebleau and stuff like that
when we did that okay yeah and that's
where like the beach is because there's
not much beach at all
because it's pretty much mangroves that
come all the way down to the water in
most places so there's not really a
shoreline except like a traditional
beach except miami beach has a heck of a
beach so that's where we went
you know when we stayed when we stayed
in miami beach yeah we did the night
swimming
yeah so night swimming was on the agenda
oh
now
we ate in some incredible food miami has
so
the food is so good we ate at this like
it was like cuban peruvian fusion or
something i don't know what it was man
but
it was
unbelievable it may have been my
favorite meal of the whole trip i mean
the food on this trip i just love eating
so much i should have a show on food
nowhere so miami
enjoy it while you can before it all
goes underwater yeah that's
that's that's what i keep thinking when
i see it i'm like man you know
this is not going to be around but
it's around now
and we go to the beach and i was like
guys one of the best experiences of my
life is night swimming and one of their
favorite songs is night swimming we have
songs that are like tied to everything
and the boys so i'm like rem yeah and so
i was like all right we go down there
now when i don't remember what time of
year it was when we night swam with
stevie and ben and alex
and not alex punched by alex alexandrov
yeah but it was
hot it was hot and the water felt like a
bath and you couldn't tell the
difference in the temperature between
the air and the water not so much the
case
in early april when we were there
so
lot was scared of sharks
and
it didn't feel great it felt great
outside of the water but it was kind of
a little chilly like when when the
bath's a little bit too cold kind of
situation okay
but i was like you guys have to get in
and sing
at least the first verse and chorus of
night swimming and then get out uh so
they did that and then
um
that was the last
so we were what we were supposed to do
night swim then go stay in our hotel
then toured the campus
couldn't get an official tour but this
campus was an open campus so we you know
we could tour it anyway
official tours were like booked or not
available on a saturday
but
there was a convergence of events
and that is
that we knew that carolina and duke were
playing each other in the final four
that night
that night saturday night and this is
the night that we're supposed to come
back and i bought these flights a long
time ago
now i'm super conflicted because
i'm an nc state grad i do not like
carolina i do not like duke i do not
like carolina more than i do not like
duke but this is like
watching
as i said on twitter the two popular
bullies in school fight it's like i
don't like either one of them but i'm
showing up for the fight yeah even i
watched it right
and if you don't have any context for
this i mean this is was the most
important college basketball game in the
history of college basketball because
this is what might be the biggest sports
rivalry i think was actually voted the
biggest sports rivalry over
uh the red sox and the yankees
by sports illustrated back in the day i
don't know about that but it is for us
the biggest thing
and they were going to be playing
literally at the same time that we were
on the plane and getting off of a plane
and getting onto another plane and i was
like
lock is a huge fan of basketball and he
really wants to watch this game i'm a
huge fan of basketball and kind of want
to begrudgingly watch this game so you
pulled an eric church i changed the
flight
i was like we're gonna we're gonna watch
this and we're gonna fly out in the
morning
uh so
yeah
we
it wasn't didn't have quite the
repercussions of uh eric church's
barbara quit scratching over there
what are you doing
i'm gonna be a troublemaker why can't
you be like jaden just sit in my lap the
whole time
um
so
we changed the flight
we watched the game
we watched the game like we watched the
first game the villanova another
villanova
whatever the first game was i've already
forgotten it it was kansas
and uh whoever they beat can't remember
and watched that first game
in a bar
and then we were like with the second
game we're gonna watch it in the comfort
of our hotel room
so we can get as loud as we want even
though we're not really i wasn't locked
was pulling for carolina
you were because he had you better be
pulling for duke so i it's this very
interesting thing
had happened to me and i talked about
this i saw you on twitter i was like
what's going on here well here's the
thing
i
i've lost some of my uh
i think that one of the things is i i
for many years now i've been able to
step outside of
the real passion and emotion that i have
around sports and understand that it is
fake passion
that it is
um the way i feel about sports and the
competitiveness of life if nc state's
playing somebody
the way i feel like my brain and my body
doesn't know the difference between a
life or death situation in nc state
sports do you nurse did that that's what
sports is like for someone who really
cares about it and i understand from an
outsider perspective that seems crazy
because it is definitively crazy to care
that much to the point that
years are coming off your life you're
doing things that are bad for your
health maybe getting yourself into a
situation where violence happens because
to other people or maybe to a wall
because you care so much about this
stuff
and something about being in la and also
my life filling up with so many other
things that like i'm just like i still
care about this but it's really hard to
get passionate about nc state athletics
when it tends to be just a marathon or
merry-go-round of disappointment a lot
of times right
so
and especially when it comes to
basketball and you live in the shadow of
duke and carolina
all these people in my family go to
carolina my wife went to carolina my
brother goes to carolina uh
my nephew goes to carolina locke
wanted to go to carolina but he's not um
and
so and i was also like i want to see
coach k go out with a win because i used
to be a duke fan when i was in high
school for no other reason than i just
like picked a team because they were
good
and i was like i'd like to see coach k
go out with a win
but then you just kind of look at this
hobbling
north carolina team where they've got
seven guys who play they got this new
coach hubert davis who i like as a
person they're playing hurt they're an
eight seed it's just like it was hard
not to pull for them but in the end i
was i got to a place where i was
literally 100 indifferent to the outcome
but still
nervous at the same time i had this
weird anxious energy watching it and i
was like you know if carolina wins this
game it'll be
it'll be crazy if coach k wins this game
it'll be fitting and like he'll go out
on a high note
and so in the end when carolina won
i just kind of felt just an empty
nothingness
and i was like i changed my flight for
nothingness
i altered my entire schedule i paid
extra money so i can watch an
emotionally
just
non-gratifying you know what i'm saying
it was just such a weird thing i was i'm
so glad i watched this historic game
but i got nothing from it it was like
eating a burger
that's made out of newspaper
oh well i don't want you to end your uh
your entire trip account on that front i
mean well that wasn't the end of
something that was the end of the trip
but let me just say
we had an incredible time
some of the i you know i couldn't i've
already gone for an hour and a half but
some of the conversations that we got
into like we got so tickled like they're
now like with shepherd being 13
the nature of the conversations and the
funny things that we talk about and the
way that we make each other laugh
it's just i really value that time that
i have with them
we just have a good you're on a 13 year
old level yeah right it's like we're all
now on the same level
and so
um
boy we just talked about so much weird
philosophical existential
funny stuff
and just you know they're both very
passionate and have a bunch of opinions
about everything just like somebody
they're related to or two people they're
related to and
i just had the best time and lock and i
we the funny thing is is lock and i had
such a great time and then the very
first night when shepherd shows up
lock's like shepherd was doing something
like he was getting in the shower and he
like left some i was like don't do that
with the towel and light was like
shepherd don't screw up our system dad
and i have a system that we have
established and you can't be messing up
the system i was like i'm proud of him i
didn't i didn't even tell him it was a
system but he picked up on the fact that
we had a system we were in a rhythm do
you use the top half of the towel he
uses the bottom half well yep well
usually there's two
uh
but yeah shepard was
shepherd was invading on the system a
little bit but he eventually fell in
line well i'm glad you guys had that you
know it's it's something you'll never
forget and if you do just listen to this
podcast
and that is the thing
i was thinking about
as i'm experiencing something like a
trip like this i'm like man i
there's a there's an impulse to write it
all down because you know you take
pictures you take video but you want to
encapsulate the whole thing well you
know what
hold that thought
because i i think there's a lot there
that i do want to unpack
and there's something that
i've experienced that i hinted to you a
little bit that i think leads to an
entirely different podcast that i think
you should re-access that okay let's put
a pin in that what i but that's why i
didn't write it down because i was like
i'm gonna talk about it for an hour and
a half in great detail
somebody just needs to
transcript it and
so i can read it as an old man
[Music]
let's just let's just post it online
yeah let's do that let's just release
this video again my wreck miami miami by
keith whitley and keith whitley as a
general recommendation
just a guy who was doing some very uh
special
specific country in the time that he was
alive 80s in the 80s and then he passed
away in 1989. and did you know that
he actually had a
he and ricky skaggs were in a bluegrass
act together and if you listen to
keith whitley eventually on spotify
because he doesn't have that many hits
because he didn't sing for that long you
get down to the album where he and ricky
skaggs did and his voice is completely
different doesn't sound like keith
whitley at all
it just sounds like a dude singing
bluegrass
barbara wasn't with us
say goodbye barbara
bye-bye
hashtag your biscuits we'll see you next
week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]